this year's HSC is fast approaching with
students gearing up for the exam
starting in October again this year
they'll be given a helping hand with the
publishing of the HSC study guides
tomorrow along with tips from some high
profile teachers
because he's the Rockstar math teacher
taking year 12 students through their
equation Paces a Cherry Brook technology
home how many years ago do you think it
was the first time you encountered
something like this Eddie Wu is one of
eight expert teachers providing tips for
the final months of HSC preparation if I
ask you to graph this what are the two
things you just found you know your
Solutions what are they
yeah fantastic so you're like bang bang
draw your Parabola off you go tomorrow
the Sydney Morning Herald owned by nine
will publish HSC study guides in 10 key
subjects it's about like utilizing every
resource you can and you know being able
to find what I need help in more than 74
000 students will do the HSC this year
sitting 124 exams across 16 days at 782
exam centers mathematics is the second
most popular subject after English
studies show that spacing out our
learning something called Wu has also
made a YouTube video that will be
released tomorrow with his top tips I
always think about mathematics and many
of the subjects as practical reading
about things and studying by looking at
notes is useful but actually students
need to challenge themselves with the
problems put themselves under test
conditions as well and he believes the
HSC study guides are incredibly valuable
firstly that they systematically go
through the wide variety of different
skills and syllabus dot points that are
important for students to master the
curriculum and then secondly it's just a
really deliberate way to structure
revision now while study is obviously
critical staying healthy is equally
important for stressed out HSC students
so as well as publishing the study
guides the city Morning Herald will have
links to tips for such things as eating
well and sleeping well and the need for
stress help is already building there's
trials coming up so that's a bit
stressful and I'm doing a major so the
pressure's building up this is the first
time we're doing like three hour exams
so like I'm just really nervous about
like writing writing like so much the
HSE study guides are available with
tomorrow's printed edition of the Sydney
Morning Herald and free online at the
SMH website in Cherry Brook Eddie Meyer
9 News